a terrible incident at the american
rapper travis scott's concert last night
he has said he's absolutely devastated
about the deaths of eight people during
that concert in texas uh we heard from
the houston mayor that uh two teenagers
were among the dead aged 14 and 16
amongst the eight dead the age ranges
were 14 to 27
all of them pointing out that
travis scott has a young following 25
people in total were transported to
hospital 13 people are still
hospitalized of whom five are under the
age of 18. we heard there about the
permits for the site that some 200 000
people could be at the venue but the
numbers were limited to 50 000 separate
stages crowds subdivided but the big
investigation is what caused the crowd
to surge lots of security on site too
both by the houston police department
and private security too
and um also talking about some of the
rumors on the internet and the
suggestion that a security officer who
appeared to be injected in the neck uh
at this concert had to be revived with
narcan and certainly seemed to have a
pinprick in his neck uh
injected the suggestion is by a concert
goer before passing out that is also a
line of inquiry but a thorough
investigation promised